hey everyone did I miss a meeting sorry
I was shot getting code Reds with my
party best of a husband I don't care if
it's unprofessional I just want to have
fun and do Molly ready unicorns what
that was spot on Cheyenne oh my God
Mateo we can see your junk what oh my
God
tail that was not okay what are you
gonna hit him too no Sandra we've moved
on look what Jeff just sent me
my precious treasure words cannot
express my love for you
and I love seeing you naked because it's
really good
love Mr Man wow
Jeff sent you those that's like a
hundred dollar bouquet yeah like 140. it
seems so weird you'd send you a gift to
work when your relationship is supposed
to be secret I guess he really loves me
huh yeah hey Heather look what just sent
me
oh we need more tissue paper
what's wrong with him
well it's because of a reason that I I
can't tell you I actually don't care
Matteo's the one dating Jeff okay and
Sandra is just making it up to get
attention
so Sandra has a fake boyfriend she sent
herself flowers and Matteo is Danny Jeff
yeah
it's a quality Tuesday
[Laughter]
it's so embarrassing I always tell him
Jeff you're gifted enough for me but he
won't listen I'm not much of a romantic
but this is special stuff
whatever do you know how many babies
chuckling balloons and die every year I
don't know but it seemed like a few wood
I'm just happy for Sandra I mean can you
imagine what it's like to have what she
has I mean just to have a connection
like that with someone
I bet Jeff just loves it 30. 30 babies
die who went away with you that weekend
grandmother died foolish girl she's
alive and well Nana's in on it too so
they're still beefing oh yeah they're
going at it it's Savage well believe
this Bo and I have a deeper connection
than you'll ever have this whole time I
thought that you were my friend but
really you were only using me to get to
Bow yes it was the ultimate betrayal oh
man God what they're saying
written it's written here I gotta tell
Marcus and Sandra
what
ultimately Trail wait a minute do you
guys write this out ahead of time is
this fake where did you know you're
crazy I absolutely slept with Bo and his
grandmother's meth Bungalow this is
ridiculous whatever wait no come on come
on you guys we're fighting yeah we just
jotted down a couple of bullet points
okay this is way more interesting than
some nobody getting dumped whoa well I'd
rather be a nobody than a couple of
impossible Burgers because all I'm
seeing here is some imitation beef
I should be funny oh it's funny hello
everyone I am Jonah and I am I'm excited
to be here this is going to be fun so my
name is Mateo Fernando Aquino Diwana and
I'm here to make something for myself
spread my wings
see how far I Can Fly
thank you
thank you yeah I I too would like to see
how far I Can Fly
so
saved it now I used to in these meetings
with some wisdom from the good book but
then someone reported me to corporate
heck yeah I did look I'm a Christian too
but in these four walls my Bible is the
employee code of conduct we all thank
you for it yeah you're welcome
I pray for you Dina I pray for you too
I'm praying right now it's so hard
I'm praying harder than you I know how
so uh to welcome our new employees
[Music]
welcome welcome to Cloud Nine This Is My
Jam
excuse me excuse me hi
um I hung up everything that was in the
dressing rooms and I organized it by
style color size and relevance of
designer wow good job I enjoy hard work
it's just like my mom always said if you
don't work hard baby Jesus will cry
okay I don't think I could be happy
fooling around in a parking lot like the
other new guy Mateo
I'm such a thirsty hey there he is
first I was like is that my tail or the
rock hi Jeff what brings you to the
store again now for someone who works at
corporate you're here a lot well I'm not
going to forget about my peeps just
because I got promoted I mean I can
still stop by now and then isn't it like
a five hour drive from Chicago not on a
corporate jet
which I didn't take this time but I have
seen the corporate jet really cool wings
anyway uh if you guys ever wanted to
come visit me I'd love to show you
around shy Town they've got some great
museums I think and you know if it's a
fun night I've got a big place you can
stay over it's Jeff I've moved on okay
I've moved on to God get over yourself I
am doing very well
so anyways let me give you guys my
business cards give me a call for any
reason is fine of course always here to
help
are you not gonna I'm only because if I
get a finite amount and they eventually
it starts to come out of my paycheck you
know I'm gonna go ahead and take it back
now okay guys it's the best part amen
you've done so much for me
you gave me this job
you've helped me through some
some hard times and if it weren't for
you I never would have met my boyfriend
right because even though I said stop
I'm not gonna date your brother even
when it became a clear HR violation it
is it just kept pushing and
maybe you're right
who can say if I've been changed for the
better
because I knew you
[Music]
you cause I knew you be because
I have been changed
[Music]
for good
that'll do pig excuse me like what if
Miracle on 34th Street took place on the
first day of the LA riots
let's find out this doesn't seem
Christmassy so the idea there is
post-apocalyptic Christmas like what if
the Grinch has succeeded in conquering
Whoville and City Lou who grew up got
boobs and was leading the resistance
like not that exactly but in that area
I don't want to be insulting but are we
sure that idea is not just pure gay
nonsense
Tina I'm trying to give you something
original
something that will make ugly Denise
want to walk into the ocean can you
please just trust me honestly that's
going to be tough
I've always had this weird thing about
people with glasses when I was younger a
nearsighted man bit me you know it's a
long story I got Hep a I'm okay now but
uh
all right
let's see what else you got okay this
next outfit answers the question what if
cogsworth from Beauty and the Beast
was a hot twin yes now just Reach Out
And Touch the polar bear okay you're not
afraid he just ate a seal so he's not
gonna eat you like
like this yes
ah now try smiling but only using your
eyes and ears
yes you are killing it oh
what do you think
wow
pictures make me jealous of everyone
I've ever had sex with what do you think
should we take a couple more
I'm very comfortable with nudity you're
a young girl from Nazareth you're
pregnant with Jesus and you're trying to
make a go of it in a new city but you're
lost oh you're lost in New York
let me know if this is too much no it's
good I feel like I'm European what I'm
having a really good time with you
okay this really has nothing to do with
Christmas but it's very important to me
that we do this
hey what's up Dean uh I need you to sign
this uh
sign what what Garrett please this is a
hot set oh yeah no I know it's just uh
yeah I'm gonna I'm cool
okay huh oh yeah
no worries I'm out of here oh
all right well I'll see y'all later Hang
Ten
foreign
work everyone Darren I will see you
Friday night at zippers
okay what do you think
oh well I look like a hot glowing
Stanley Tucci look sorry redundant much
Dina I know right so do you think we've
got it these are good but I have one
more really great idea
might seem a little crazy
do you trust me
we're so lucky that Darren had this
harness in his trunk huh